GRIFF: WE’RE BACK WITH A FOX
NEWS ALERT THE NUMBER OF U.S.
CORONAVIRUS RELATED DEATHS
NOW SURPASSING 2,000 DOUBLING IN
JUST TWO DAYS THERE ARE MORE
THAN 124,000 CASES NOW,
NATIONWIDE.
JEDEDIAH: THIS AS HILLARY
CLINTON TAKES TO TWITTER TO MOCK
THE PRESIDENT’S AMERICA FIRST
AFTER THE U.S. REACHED THE MOST
CASES IN THE WORLD TWEETING "HE
DID PROMISE AMERICA FIRST."
PETE: DISGUSTING THOSE COMMENTS
NOT SITTING WELL WITH
CONGRESSMAN DAN CRENSHAW FIRING
RIGHT BACK ON TWITTER CALLING
HER OUT FOR POLITICAL OPPORTUN
ISM LET’S BRING IN THAT
MAN RIGHT NOW, GOP CONGRESSMAN
DAN CRENSHAW, FORMER NAVY SEAL
AND AUTHOR OF THE FORTHCOMING
NEW BOOK, GREAT ONE, FORTITUDE,
AMERICAN RESILIENCE IN THE ERA
OF OUTRAGE.
CONGRESSMAN WE LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING A COPY OF YOUR BOOK,
SOON COMES OUT IN EARLY APRIL,
BUT WHEN YOU SAW THAT TWEET FROM
HILLARY CLINTON, THERE’S ONE
MOMENT AND ONE THING WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO AVOID POLITICS ON,
IT’S THIS , AND THEN SHE TWEETS
THAT?
>> YEAH, EXACTLY AND YOU
MENTIONED IN MY BOOK ONE OF THE
THINGS I TALK A LOT ABOUT IS
OUTRAGE CULTURE AND THIS NEW
FOUND ISSUE WHERE WE
FIND THE WORST OF EACH OTHER,
RIGHT?
AND WE QUESTION EACH OTHER’S
INTENTIONS AND THAT HAPPENS ALL
THE TIME IN POLITICS BUT NOW IS
NOT THE TIME TO DO THAT.
THERE IS A PANDEMIC GOING ON AND
SOMEBODY LIKE HILLARY CLINTON IS
SO USED TO TAKING POLITICAL JABS
AT THE PRESIDENT OR  HER
POLITICAL OPPONENTS ANY TIME
THERE’S AN OUTCOME THAT IS
UNFORTUNATE, BUT THIS ISN’T THE
TIME.
THIS IS A TRAGEDY FOR  ALL
AMERICANS FOR THE ENTIRE WORLD,
AND IT’S JUST NOT THE TIME AND
THIS IS WHAT WORRIES ME ABOUT
THE FUTURE IS WE HAVE DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW TO MOVE
FROM RISK CONTAINMENT TO RISK
MITIGATION TO RISK MANAGEMENT
OPENING UP SOCIETY ALONG WITH
THE THREAT OF THE PANDEMIC.
IT’S GOING TO BE EASY TO TAKE
SWIPES AT EACH OTHER AND EASY TO
HAVE VERY DISINGENUINOUS
CRITICISMS OF EACH OTHER AND
MORALIZE AGAINST EACH OTHER
BUT WE CAN’T DO THAT.
WE HAVE TO DO THIS TOGETHER.
JEDEDIAH: CONGRESSMAN I WANT TO
ASK YOU ABOUT TEXAS BECAUSE IN
AN ATTEMPT TO PREVENT TEXAS FROM
BECOMING THE NEXT POTENTIAL
HOTSPOT, GOVERNOR ABBOTT
REQUIRED TRAVEL TRAVELERS TO UK.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
DECISION?
>> WELL I THINK THIS IS GOING
TO BE THE FUTURE AND IT’S THE
RIGHT TARGETED APPROACH,
OKAY?
WE’RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO USE
DATA TO SEE WHERE THE HOTSPOTS
ARE AND TAKE THIS SORT OF
VERTICAL APPROACH AND MOVE AWAY
FROM THE HORIZONTAL APPROACH
WHERE WE QUARANTINE EVERYBODY
AND WE START LOOKING AT WHO ARE
OUR MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE,
WHERE ARE THE HOTSPOTS AS WE
RAMP UP TESTING WE’LL HAVE MORE
DATA TO INFORM THOSE DECISIONS
AND THIS IS ON THE BACKS OF
GOVERNORS AND MAYORS AND I THINK
THIS SAID SOMETHING ELSE.
AS AMERICANS WE TEND TO KEEP
LOOKING FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
MICRO MANAGE OUR SITUATION.
THAT’S REALLY NOT HOW OUR SYSTEM
WORKS, IT NEVER HAS AND IT NEVER
WILL.
EVERY CITY HAS DIFFERENT NEEDS.
EVERY CITY HAS DIFFERENT
PREFERENCES, DIFFERENT PROBLEMS
AND GOVERNORS AND MAYORS ARE
REALLY RUNNING THIS SHOW AND I
THINK WOULD BE HOVER AMERICANS
TO UNDERSTAND THAT A LITTLE BIT
MORE AND LOOKING TO THEIR LOCAL
OFFICIALS FOR HOW MANY
VENTILATORS ARE COMING IN, WHEN
IS THE  PPE.
WE KEEP LOOKING TO THE PRESIDENT
TO DO THAT AND IT’S REALLY NOT
HOW THIS WORKS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS THERE
TO SUPPORT THE EFFORTS OF OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
GRIFF: CONGRESSMAN I WANT TO ASK
YOU ABOUT, I DON’T NEED TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT RESILIENCE MY
GOODNESS WITH YOUR EXPERIENCE
BUT THE PRESIDENT YESTERDAY, I
THINK SPOKE SOME WORDS THAT
REALLY MAY IGNITE A FIRE IN SOME
PEOPLE FEELING ANXIETY AND
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH WHAT THEY’VE
GOT TO TOUGHEN UP.
HERE WAS THE PRESIDENT IN
NORFOLK YESTERDAY.
LISTEN TO THIS AND I WANT TO GET
YOUR REACTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THE WORLD HAS
WITNESSED THE UNYIELDING RESOLVE
OF OUR INCREDIBLE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WE ARE NOT ONLY A COUNTRY OF
VAST RESOURCES, WE’RE A NATION
OF COLD OS ALL STRENGTH,
TOWERING SPIRITS, SOARING
PATRIOTISM AND EXCEPTIONAL
CHARACTER, AND YOU’RE SHOWING IT
TO THE ENTIRE WORLD.
AT THIS MOMENT.
GRIFF: CONGRESSMAN HOW IMPORTANT
ARE WORDS LIKE THAT AT THIS TIME
>> I THINK UNBELIEVABLY
IMPORTANT AND WE SHOULD STOP
DOWNPLAYING AND CRITICIZING WELL
WE AREN’T DOING IT BUT A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE, THE PRESIDENT
EVERY TIME HE DOES SOMETHING
LIKE THIS OR  TRIES TO GIVE
AMERICANS HOPE OR  TRIES TO
POINT OUT THE POSITIVE THINGS
ABOUT WHAT’S GOING ON.
THAT’S OKAY.
LET’S EMBRACE THAT.
JUST THIS ONCE, LET’S EMBRACE
SOME OF THE GOOD THINGS
HAPPENING LET’S EMBRACE THE FACT
THAT OUR INDUSTRIES HAVE TOTALLY
RAMPED UP PRODUCTION OF PPE,
FACTORIES ARE TOTALLY CHANGING
WHAT THEY DO TO MAKE VENTILATORS
, THAT PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY COMING TOGETHER AND
FIGURING OUT WHAT NEEDS TO GET
DONE.
DOCTORS ARE COMING OUT OF
RETIREMENT.
YOU KNOW, WE RAMPED UP TESTING
TO AN ENORMOUS DEGREE IN THIS
COUNTRY WHICH IS WHY OUR
CASES ARE SO HIGH, HILLARY
CLINTON.
NOW, LET’S CELEBRATE THIS STUFF.
LET’S WORK TOGETHER, LET’S STOP
LOOKING FOR CHEAP POLITICAL JABS
TO TAKE AT EACH OTHER AND
ACTUALLY GET THROUGH THIS.
PETE: THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE’RE ACTUALLY TRANSPARENT ABOUT
OUR NUMBERS BECAUSE WE DON’T LIE
TO THE PEOPLE IN THE WORLD LIKE
THE COMMUNIST CHINESE DO AND WE
HAVE RAPID TESTING AS A RESULT
THE NUMBERS WILL GO UP YOU CAN
POINT THAT OUT WITHOUT BEING
PARTISAN.
WE’VE BEEN ASKING OUR VIEWERS TO
SEND IN PHOTOS THAT MOTIVATE AND
INSPIRE.
HERE IS ONE FROM LAUREN FROM
TEXAS.
SENDING THIS ONE WITH HIS DOG,
BRANDY HE VOWS TO HOLD THIS ONE
MAN AND DOG PARADE WITH THE FLAG
EVERY MORNING UNTIL THE CRISIS
ENDS.
JEDEDIAH: HERE IS ONE FROM ERIC
AND LISA.
THEY SAY THEY FLY THE LAG TO
SALUTE THESE WONDERFUL OFTEN UN
RECOGNIZED HEROS.
GRIFF: AND ROBERT SENDS THIS
WITH A 26-FOOT FLAG POLE
NOW IN FRONT OF HIS PROPERTY,
THEY SAY EVERYTHING IN TEXAS IS
BIGGER, AND CONGRESSMAN, THAT
CERTAINLY WOULD APPLY THERE.
>> YEAH, IT IS TRUE, AND I LOVE
SEEING THIS KIND OF STUFF.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT I’M TALKING
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW, OUR FLAG IS SO
IMPORTANT.
THAT’S WHY I HATE SEEING PEOPLE
DESTROY IT, BECAUSE THIS IS A
SYMBOL THAT BRINGS US TOGETHER.
IT MEANS SOMETHING TO US.
IT’S A SYMBOL OF OUR FOUNDING,
OF OUR HISTORY, AND OF THESE
VALUES THAT MAKE US AMERICAN AND
THOSE VALUES ARE COURAGE AND
STRENGTH AND THE ABILITY TO
OVERCOME ANYTHING, AND SO I JUST
LOVE SEEING THAT STUFF.
PETE: GREAT STUFF.
JEDEDIAH: FORTITUDE RESILIENCE
IN THE ERA OF OUTRAGE.
THANK YOU, CONGRESSMAN FOR
JOINING US TODAY.